تداعيات تاخر التوصل الى حل ازمه سقف
الدين العام في الولايات المتحده يبدو
انها بدات مبكرا قبل قضاء المهله المحدده
بعد اكثر من شهر من الان ومعها ترتفع
المخاوف من تاثر الاقتصاد العالمي العد
العكسي بدا مشاهدينا ماذا لو تخلفت
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها لاول مره
في تاريخها وهل يهتز هنا النظام المالي
العالمي بعدما وضعت وكاله فيتش التصنيف
الائتمانيه الولايات المتحده تحت المراقبه
ولمنع هذا الامر يتعين على الكونجرس
الامريكي ان يرفع في اسرع وقت ممكن سقف
الدين العام او ان يعلق العمل به لتجنب
وقوع الولايات المتحده بالكارثه وفق
الخبراء الماليين وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
واضبت على اصدار تصريحات متكرره تقول فيها
بان الولايات المتحده قد تتخلف عن سداد
الديون اعتبارا من يونيون المقبل وفي حال
تخلفت الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها قد
يؤدي ذلك الى تسريح الملايين من الموظفين
عن عملهم في البلاد طبعا كما قد يؤدي الى
وضع حد مؤقت لعمليه استرداد الضرائب
والضمان الاجتماعي والرعايه الطبيه هذا
مشاهدينا على الصعيد المحلي اما على
الصعيد العالمي فيرى هنا المراقبون بان
هناك مخاوف كثيره من اهتزاز ثقه المقرضين
وتراجع مكانه الدولار كعمله احتياطيه
ويمكن ان يكون لفقدان الثقه بالدولار
تداعيات بعيده المدى على الاقتصاد
والسياسه الخارجيه ايضا لان الدول الاخرى
وتحديدا هنا الصين وروسيا
ستستخدمان التخلف الامريكي عن السداد لدفع
عملتهما الخاصه لتصبح بمثابه اساس التجاره
العالميه مستقبلا طبعا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات